now let's jump into that first story
this is from
business politics uh biz pack review
misguided embrace of mob justice doesn't
end well
for blue check who took on ann coulter
it's an excellent
uh title of the article but let's give
you the gist of it because we have the
article here and we have uh ann coulter
i mentioned this in the opening but for
those who are just joining in there was
a very
there was a very serious tragedy where
uh a man and his girlfriend were
celebrating puerto rican day and they
were flying the flag
in the humboldt park neighborhood of
chicago they got ambushed
somehow they ended up outside of their
car either dragged out or fell out and
they were shot the man was effectively
executed the woman was left for dead
in critical condition and they were
rushed to the hospital this is a
horrifying story
but this blue checkmark on twitter the
founder of a democrat
political action committee said and you
forgot to mention that he was flying a
confederate flag and he was white
as if that somehow justified murdering a
man in cold blood
and when people called him out he was
like okay i was wrong about the flag i
get that but i was just saying if it was
a white guy
like even doubling down this is this
to me it's a shocking uh example of
where we are today
in mainstream politics or i guess this
is
more worrying maybe this is just what
people have always thought they just
didn't have a venue to
blast it out to the world when ann
coulter would appear on fox news and say
these things
this guy would probably be sitting in
his lounge chair in his living room
saying the exact same thing
it's only now that we can see what they
think because they're willing to say it
to everybody i guess
truth be told back then without twitter
they probably would have still been
willing to say it
they just didn't have any way to do it
so maybe that's what's really happening
but uh earlier ron you were mentioning
that
you're not even surprised by this and
it's like not even news
no i mean it's news that he that anyone
noticed
[Laughter]
yeah i'll tell you i mean worrying it's
only a couple of clicks away
from last night you know very often so
i i have a i don't have a tim pool kind
of
twitter account but i've got you know
130 some odd thousand
and a blue check oh you're one of them
i'm blue check two yeah i know probably
of course yeah blue checkers
and often i will get into you know i'll
i'll scroll down into look what looks
like a fun scrum
and say you know this looks like some i
can't i should be able to get a couple
of good one
good one-liners off here that's kind of
my mo
and then i bring the culmination in
that's the name of my podcast
culmination
the coleman although it was really meant
as a pun on culmination
that's a good one like just like the sex
pistols were the band that killed rock
and roll i wanted to be the podcaster
that killed
podcasting but not until i made a ton of
money at it see
um and i
it was an ashley babbitt
thread and inevitably there's some
awful person saying well she got exactly
what she deserved
well it was someone who said ashley webb
got justice on january 6th
right that's horrifying oh in that
in every single ashley babbitt threat
so and so often people will say to me
why did i tell you how big my account
was because all people
ron why are you bothering this person he
has 700 followers
answer i'm not doing it for him
he's not gonna no one changes his mind
on twitter
we know that but i do have a lot of
people who are interested in how
ron will deal with this issue or with
this
comment because they look
to me for a certain kind of rhetorical
leadership we might call it
so i sort of started up with this guy
and he
he was absolutely but you can find it
all the time you know often i'll say
well
breaking and entering is actually not
this
well it's breaking and entering you know
you can shoot some no breaking and
entering is in a house
in washington dc it doesn't have to be
at night necessarily but it
it isn't a public building that wasn't
breaking and entering second
there is a standard a legal standard for
the use of
force and this didn't resemble that in
the slightest now
as i said this is a couple of clicks
away from
displaying a flag which involves no
violence or threat of violence there's
no misjudgment
that was just plain murder right this
was
frankly i wouldn't want to say anything
too too out there that i've already said
on twitter but i've said it
people are absol i think tim you
absolutely nailed it
people just feel comfortable saying it
now
someone who thinks like that has always
thought like that or
they grew up in a house where mom and
pop
or bomb or pop thought like that
that's that's i think that's the only
thing that's changed well i think it's
possible that
um social media has driven these people
insane in the sense of uh
they like to talk about the rabbit hole
like these new york times reporters and
these nbc reporters
it's not true in the way they think it
is they're like oh youtube's algorithm
makes people go on a rabbit hole
which makes no sense because it's only
ever politics right they make this claim
that
if someone watches a video on
immigration within a month they'll be
you know far right or whatever
but if that were the case that that
there would be a rabbit hole for every
subject it's like you watch a cartoon
about batman
and then the month you've got batman
posters all over your walls and you're
running around the city just like batman
well i've become obsessed with with
world war one flamethrowers
oh the original assault anyone getting
that anyway is anyone getting that
reference
no it's a thomas wichter reference well
so so but
what i do think happens though is
communities can rile people up and
twitter and facebook are the actual
culprit of radicalization not so much
youtube in fact
youtube act gives you a big mix because
it doesn't just send you down one
direction
oh all i will say though youtube did
have some element of this where it's
like you get the same content over and
over
i wouldn't say it radicalize you other
than that it showed you the same thing
over and over on twitter
you do get radicalized because what
happens is you're looking for retweets
and everybody's constantly one-upping
each other to be that top figure the
same thing is true with these blogs like
buzzfeed and with vox and with facebook
you're constantly trying to shock people
into sharing content
youtube doesn't have a direct share
feature the way that twitter and
facebook does
if you want to share a youtube video and
you should share this one by taking the
url and posting it on facebook and
twitter
you have to actually manually do it this
is why it's very very difficult
for youtube centric conversations to
expand to a larger level
people who are watching this have to
actually go into the url copy it
then paste it on another platform or
there's a share button they can click
and then select a platform and then open
up a window
and that platform may or may not preview
well
and if it doesn't it's dead on arrival
now let's let's think about
how twitter and facebook works with this
like radicalization is extremism and
this guy i mean
this is literally a story about a guy
going on twitter saying it was okay for
people to be executed using his own name
there's a real person this is not like
you're verified right it's because when
he tweets
he's hoping someone will hit the retweet
button and on the
spot relay his message to hundreds more
so what happens is people keep trying to
find
what will get them attention when they
find it
they attack it like crazy getting more
and more retweets
going more and more insane i want to
suggest that it's not always
such an intense thing i think there's
actually in a way
what i want to say here is a little
scarier even
if you tell me that people are going to
say shocking things in order to get
attention
and this goes back to like the skinheads
the punks
using uh you know swastikas are they
nazis
oh johnny rotten has a swastika
therefore he wants to round up the jews
no no what it means is that he wants to
shock you horrify you get
your attention i'm not saying it's cool
i'm just saying
chill out
what you're seeing a lot of with
people in this highly politicized
environment is
casual casual
expressions of ugly thoughts
in other words i had a tweet i guess it
was
three or four days ago i write these
really elaborate threads
i am i am bringing
the very substance of godly wisdom to my
people i write these
incredibly insightful and original
threads and i often get nice traction
but but then listen if you knew how
humble i was being in describing it that
way
but but i had 6 000 tweets for the
following
tweet a a quote tweet of biden
announcing that he told the russians the
16 things
they absolutely positively can't do and
i said is this a parody
okay now that went viral
that was a casual that was like a gimme
that was
that was this chip shot i just felt like
i had to say something
but i didn't i didn't but it got me a
gazillion followers
or a gazillion clicks you know they're
not too sticky they're not right they're
not too sticky
but there's a people who are very very
active in social media will very just
casually drop their expression
it's sort of like going to the bathroom
like oh you know i have to
i have to eliminate i have to eliminate
you know i i've built up too many
things about how stupid trump people i
need to just say that
so in other words i think in a way
that's worse because that's become
you know part of that by the way if you
want to talk are you saying that uh
twitter is basically
like a a septic tank of bad ideas like
people you build up this idea waste and
then
onto twitter and then everyone swims in
it and basks in these ideas
i think we're gonna have to think about
that a little bit
but i think you might be on to something
i think that's certainly i mean you know
what's really funny
my twitter is just like i love twitter i
hated it for a long time and then i
realized you have to love it
and uh again shout out to michael mallis
because he's the master at this
but i was just like i have learned so
much technique
from malice genius i posted it so i was
watching the movies the other day he was
a genius
and um my girlfriend mentioned that uh
like we were watching a movie where a
rabbit got run over
and you know i was jokingly like oh i
can't watch the movie anymore oh no a
rabbit's been killed it was a horror
movie i was kidding
and then uh the rabbit was by far the
least
sentient thing that was killed in that
movie for sure for sure but i
i made uh we we basically came upon the
joke that there's no such thing as an
ugly rabbit it was like a cute animal
that was killed
and so i googled it ugly rabbit and boy
are there ugly rabbits
so i just tweeted without a comment for
no reason
a picture of a hairless rabbit eating
kale
that was very wearing a scarf very silly
looking
because that's my twitter and i love it
because i tweet things and i get these
very
serious replies from these people like
you know this is probably
and i'm like bro i just posted a picture
of a hairless rabbit eating kale
who do you think you're interacting with
twitter is not the place
for me to have a serious conversation
but i'll post serious things there
no it's like a waste pit of just like
stupid things that i think i'm going to
tweet i just don't care anymore
there i don't know during the election
it was different there was so much going
on politically that i'd think of
something and be like man i can't
believe this and i just
tweet it to no one in particular and
then i just got to a point where i was
like this is an
awful vile place where people just like
want to kill each other it's it's the
fence between people for which they can
bark at each other
and so i just decided you know what i
just post insane not to this point and i
practice law
so to me i'm i'm new to that i mean
the fact is a lot of what lies right
well you know ridiculous arguments i
will tell you
really some of the finest people
to hang out with are lawyers
and and i mean the kind of lawyers who
are my kind of lawyers who are who
try cases in the courts during a break
or while waiting for
a judge the vast majority of the lawyers
that i encounter in my work they're such
a pl they're such a pleasure
i really like there's a there's a real a
real cool
aspect to that but on the other hand
as a whole in the work that we do
there's so much toleration
for falsehood
and dishonesty and i don't only mean at
the lawyer level
i mean also at the judicial level and
also at the appellate
level that you really do become very
used to
that septic tank phenomenon
unfortunately
um we're swimming in it so yeah i do
think that there is this sense that
that there's a sort of casual a casual
nastiness
that we didn't have in society before
you know you always had people who wrote
nasty letters to the editor the editors
didn't print them
right getters didn't print them or it
was the shopper
and they needed content and there was
just always the cranky guy you always
complained about
why don't people put you know the
shopping carts away you know in the stop
and shop
you know and that was their world and
yeah you know the first iteration of
this was
chain letters it's they've they started
the physical world
somebody would get a letter in the mail
and it would open it would be like you
have been cursed
like i wonder how many young people
realize these were physical letters did
you ever get a physical chain letter
sure of course
i i remember when i was little mine was
delivered by pony express you have to
keep in mind
but you're only four years ago yeah 30
years ago so uh anyway
um i i i think a lot of young people
think chain letters just started with
email
may not realize that people used to
physically mail chain like you must mail
this to 17 people
but i remember the early emails the goal
was to get maximum echo to
to to impact the world so that people
would do your thing it would have
it's a similar reason why people write
computer viruses
they want to make something influential
have an impact
graffiti right even when i was a kid so
i was growing up
in in brooklyn in this in the late 60s
and 70s
when the city began its first massive
down cycle and
people started writing on public
services this was something if you look
at photographs from the through the
1950s and early 60s
of even the most decrepit stations
there was no idea that people would
write on stuff
and even as a child i recognized because
i was an extremely socially aware child
that the people doing this obviously
are desperate to make a mark in the
world to make them
and and far be it from me
right with my 70 000 tweets a week
to look down on someone who wants to
make a mark in the world
i get it i get it and especially the
more powerless you are the
the more of a mark sometimes you want to
make because the
you know a person who's well adjusted
and who has
normal interaction with people makes a
mark by making his children happy by
making his spouse happy but
you know but there are lots of normal
healthy ways to do it in an idealized
almost
non-existent kind of existence and then
come the other
and some people need that less and some
people need it more everyone needs to
feel
valued and if you're not can't be valued
then you're gonna then you're gonna
shock the world
and twitter is this attention yes it
absolutely is that's a point system
you earn points your retweets are points
your likes are points your followers are
points
your followers are your ranking where
you are in the game
and when twitter does one of its purges
and i and when they purged the cue
people
i lost 30 000 in a week wow
now most of those people were lunatics
so you know but what about the leftist
lunatics who are tweeting things like
this
no no they get a free pass on all of it
look you've had that there's an article
going viral right now
where in 2018 newsweek was arguing that
hillary clinton could still become
president
a year into trump's presidency i
remember that very well
now you will get banned from youtube if
you say the same thing about trump right
now
if you say the same thing the same thing
we won't say
that's right that's right in fact
amazing
but but that's but that's passe we have
come to accept
that that's the way our masters
that we proceed but but
you know it is it is this point system
and
but so when they take away a massive
amount of followers from you
and now imagine when they ban somebody
so i'm one of the people who gets dm'd
or emailed when someone gets banned
because they think they think for a
reason that
does not exist by the way that i'm the
guy who can help them
because you're a lawyer i'm a lawyer and
i'm the free speech lawyer
and i'm really active on twitter
and i'm a blue check and i'm
powerful i'm not i'm not powerful at all
when i write letters and i gave up a
long time ago
to the head of the legal department at
twitter
she doesn't even bother to respond right
she doesn't bother responding and by the
way you know
invented talk about a hyperlink talk
about your adhd special moment
you know who invented the concept in my
in my 40 years on this planet since
1963.
my observation is that the concept of
absolutely ignoring your customers
for a private company that was not
actually like a utility
was microsoft the first company that
made you
buy an expensive
something from them and that you had no
expectation whatsoever
that if you had a problem or a question
that they were going to help you
monopoly power that is the way right
because what's
because what's a utility a regulated
monopoly
right and when you see a company acting
like a utility
ding-a-ling-a-ling thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out
and we'll see you all next time